changes from an external point okay
again we're going to draw a picture to
intuitively understand what this
property is and then we'll prove it very
very quickly so what this means is when
you have a circle an external point as
the name suggests is a point that is
external for the circle that's outside
so just not long as the government's not
inside somewhere anywhere pick a point
and make sure you've got it outside
right now grab your ruler and this one
will do what I want you to do is draw
the tangents because there's two of them
from your point to the circle okay so
for instance here magnets okay you've
got your ruler there so you can fairly
precisely place your ruler so it will
just nicely touch and then go ahead and
join it up so here's one of my teachers
and then here is my other changer okay
now strictly speaking what this property
is talking about is not the entire
tangent because the tender can go on
forever or stop at some indeterminate
point well we're really talking about is
from the external point to the point of
contact or the points of contact I
should say we have an answer just by the
way when you've got an interval or a
line it's broken up into pieces it
started I didn't remember we call this
the intercepts in this context that's
what intercepts means so really what
this means is intercepts on tangents
from an external point but we sort of
get what you mean and this is one of the
nice points where we don't make you
write everything have a look those
intercepts on that on those pages what
they look like you can even measure they
sure look equal don't they they look
equal go ahead measure put your ruler
there can we prove that these two
lengths see let's give them some names
that's a bad name let's call that our P
a and B are on the circle so they're
different kinds of points can we prove
that PA equals P B
let me give you a tip a really easy
proof for this will flows directly out
of the property we just proved that
tends to perpendicular would anyone like
to make a suggestion for what I might
construct I gave you a big clue when I
talked about this I I have pages what's
the thing that's missing in here that
might be useful here radii okay why are
we construction radio okay I've got some
radio those look good
what else should I do yeah constructed a
B you're talking about this line across
here that correct okay now I'm going to
pause for a minute as we as I cry and
point out to you all the time which is
one of the things I love that geometry
many different ways to solve this okay a
B a B constructing that is totally fine
you can get to a proof from there it's a
little less direct which is surprising
now you don't know that cuz you started
this out yet I'm going to go down a
different path and I will leave it as an
exercise to the reader to prove it by
constructing a B and seeing what comes
out of that I'm going to make one side a
different construction which is I'm
going to join your external point to the
center you do that boy okay so we're
very close now if I want to prove that
PA equals PB how will I go about doing
it what properties can I take advantage
of here say it again put okay when you
have a look at this you've actually done
a couple steps we've got two triangles
if PA and PB are equal then it says the
reason they should be in contractors
even look congruent don't it right so
therefore the proof that we could go for
it is RHS why would that be a sensible
directly going because you have right
angles we just proved that in the first
property here right so let's go ahead
and put those right angles in when you
do this properly you'll actually have to
you know write this all out but I just
want to get the skeleton of the proof
there for you
you got your right angles so tick for
our what about H
it's a common sight it's in both
triangles that's great
so tic 4-h what about the other side
these guys are really owned a circle
okay
tick tick tick you're done okay and that
gives you the last side make sense okay
change into conviction of the razor
point of contact change it's from an
external point are equal here comes the
last one which looks like it has nothing
to do with Tanja's again I'm going to
ask you to draw these you'll need to
draw two circles that touch two circles
that touch I will point out you could do
this in a couple of different ways you
could draw them probably the way you're
picturing like this beside each other
but you could just as easily draw one
inside the other and they're still
touching and this property that we're
going to describe still works okay but
probably it makes it it'll be easiest
for your brain if you do the original
one so just draw two circles and just
make sure they just touch centers and
point of contact centers and point of
contact on your circles go ahead find
the center of the first one find the
center in the second one and then
highlight the point of contact look at
your diagram what does it look like
these things to share we have a word for
this we have one word starts with a c'
it looks like they're collinear it looks
like they sit on a straight line right
and in fact if you've drawn good circles
unlike mine which are sort of freehand
then you can put the ruler and you can
see it very nicely so excuse me what I'm
trying to prove is sentient and point of
contact are collinear in touching
circles okay how will I do it any
suggestions again a construction will be
useful
okay yep yeah you can appeal to the
perpendicular height of triangles that's
true it's going to be a little it's
going to be a bit work to get there is
there any quicker way that we could do
it Eric so it seems like it would
behoove us to actually create some
tangents on here being that I gave you
the big flash include the tangents are
going to be useful in this case even
though there are no changes right now
the question is where do I put the pages
okay so this is where I'm going to type
or suggestion this is where this
actually is a tangent property because
when we say like what does it mean
pertains to sorry what is the need for
circles to be touching
what's an actual formal definition for
that this is worth writing down touching
circles are circles with a common
tangent at a common point right so you
can obviously draw any two random
circles like this and they can share a
common tangent you just sort of join
them up like that but what we mean is
the common tangent is at a common point
let's go ahead and draw it in line is
going to look something like this
can you see how quickly this proof is
going to fall out it's going to not
going to take many steps at all right
what shall I say let's give these names
shall we let's call this x and y we'll
call this P and Q and this is in the
middle so let's call it M what would you
like me to say okay you can see some
right angles name some form you p.m. X
is a right angle because tangent art so
you've got that property that's great
but that doesn't make a straight line
ah-huh so when you go in the opposite
direction in a different circle the same
property right so the way that you would
say this by the way is you would state
what you just said in circle X and then
you don't have to write that property
again you'd say similarly in circle y
dot dot dot and then off you go you've
got a 90 and got a 91 is that proof
you've got this and we we always use
this property the other way we know that
something is a straight line and so we
say the angles add up to 180 degrees but
now we can use the converse if angles
honest if angles add up to 180 degrees
they are a straight line does that make
sense